hey everyone so i have been getting
ready for one of the biggest red carpets
of the season and i can't believe i
actually get to go that's going to be so
much fun but it is quite a process to
get ready now as much as i would like to
just roll out of bed and wear my
sweatpants to the red carpet guess what
you guys can't do that this is kind of
my week leading up to the big event so
come with me as i prepare for the big
day tuesday
first up is some crest white strips now
these usually take about 30 minutes so
i'm gonna see how fit i can get in that
time
back from the workout teeth are whitened
and now it's on with the day
wednesday
time to do the nails
so good nails did now it's time
thursday
to get my skin real fresh i'm gonna
throw on one of these face masks
all right
now to watch every nominated film
right now
this is so good
how good is so good oh my god he is so
good she's good too
what are they getting some cookies
friday never hurts to have a
professional makeup artist so francesca
came by to help me with a few really
great new looks
hello dolly hi i got you a little treat
thank you
really excited all right you know you
have two days left until the red carpet
and we have not decided on a final lip
color for you yes how about chocolate
i
always like the real basic pink right
like a basic pick yes and it looks
beautiful on you but i thought maybe we
could branch out and try something else
that might show up your smile a little
bit more dramatically all right
i trust you okay
what do you think
no
um
i think
no
oh
your teeth look bright
look
i actually really like it
do you really i do i mean i don't really
know if i can really wear it but i like
it you like it
yeah
all right so i have something that's
kind of in the same vein as that
shocking pink but it's a little bit more
subdued
oh that's beautiful i okay i really like
this i think this is it maybe it can
make it a little glossier
what's great about this color is it's a
blue based pink so it really helps
brighten your teeth and make them look
dazzling
i think that's like my favorite color
really like yeah i just picked my
favorite color right now you mean we've
been wearing the wrong color i think so
it's good to step out of the box a
little bit
i love it it's really fun i think it
looks great on you thank you your teeth
look super dazzling white and i think
you're gonna stun them on the red carpet
do you like it i do okay good my work
here is done i'm out of here
thank you guys so much for watching i
hope you enjoyed this fun video of the
getting ready for the big red carpet i
mean we did it all we got the nails done
we got the crest white strips i even did
a face mask and i worked out but what i
want to know from you guys is what is
your favorite lip color you guys can
tweet it to me using the hashtag
smilestyle and i will be retweeting a
few of my favorites but now most
importantly francesca
can you order pizza
it's on its way
life is great
pizza party oh god i'm a spell see ya